It's official.
Taylor Swift is a billionaire.
Welcome to the Eras Tour.
Her Eras Tour alone is a party, generating
hundreds of millions of dollars.
It's a multinational conglomerate
with the world's most devoted
customer base
and an ultra-charismatic CEO.
Never before have we ever seen an artist
put multiple stadium
shows on sale in the same city
and blow them all out.
But how much of the money has gone
into that CEO's pocket?
We've crunched the numbers to come up
with the most definitive account
yet of Taylor Swift's wealth.
And here it is.
Bloomberg has a team
that tallies up how much the world's
wealthiest people are worth.
It's based on careful calculation
and analysis
of all their income and assets.
Taylor has become a billionaire
not just because people like her songs,
but because of a lot of smart business
decisions that she's made over the years.
Taylor Swift is a phenomenon,
but she's hardly the first billionaire
in the music industry.
There's the record label scion
David Geffen,
there’s Jay-Z, Rihanna, the late
Jimmy Buffett and plenty of others.
While those billionaires use their fame
as the foundation for other business ventures,
Swift has made her fortune
almost exclusively from her music.
She has really come out openly
about the importance
of controlling your music
and owning your music as an artist.
So, where exactly does her wealth
come from?
Let's start with streaming.
The rise of Spotify, Apple Music
and others has created
a resurgence in the recording industry.
We estimate that her total income
from streaming is 175 million.
Clearly not a number to sniff at,
but one reason it's
not bigger is because of the way
royalties are distributed.
Typically, what happens is artists
don't own the masters of their music,
but they get royalties from it.
The owners of the masters
generally keep 4/5 of the royalties,
while the copyright holders, the composers
and lyricists, keep the rest.
So what Taylor has done recently
and has been a very smart business
decision is to rerecord her albums
and then own the masters of those.
So with this rerecording exercise, she's
kind of taking back control of her music.
She's reclaiming ownership of it,
but she's also diluting the value
of the masters to the first six albums
that are originally out there.
Swift also took the battle
to the streamers themselves.
So in 2014, Taylor Swift
pulled all of her music off of Spotify.
She did it in protest of what she said
was unfair compensation from the streamer.
That gave her the upper hand
when she renegotiated her rates
to join Spotify again in 2017.
She's also done a great job in promoting
physical album sales
online through Twitter, Instagram,
other social media networks.
So, fans have an incentive
to buy physical records.
She's leveraged social media
and kind of connecting with fans,
getting to know them on a personal level,
sharing information about herself,
kind of creating this intimacy
which has created
this really, really powerful fan base
who connect with her.
Bloomberg estimates Swift has made
$125 million over the years from record sales.
She also made strong strategic choices
at the negotiating table.
In 2018, she left her longtime
record label,
Big Machine, to go independent.
She negotiated a new contract
with Universal Music Group
in 2018 that allows her
to take a larger share of the royalties.
The biggest part of her earnings
is undoubtedly her concert revenue.
Taylor Swift's concerts have generated
at least $1.6 billion,
and that is only ticket sales, that’s
not including merchandise.
She's done six tours over the years since 2009.
Most recently, the Eras Tour.
It came right as everyone
was starved for live events.
People were coming out of the pandemic
and really wanted a chance
to gather in person and celebrate.
And there are people
that are willing to spend anything
and everything to get a chance to see her.
A splurge, for sure. But I got to do it.
We've just been trying
without mortgaging the house.
Of course, she doesn't keep all of that money.
We estimate that Taylor nets
about 35% of the ticket sales as profit,
about 500 million
from touring over the years.
Her tours, her record sales and streaming
royalties are all earnings.
But she also has assets,
including her recording catalog.
There's the masters’ rights,
then there’s the publishing rights.
Catalog is a collection of songs
all grouped under one artist.
Every time a song in this catalog is played,
it generates a royalty,
which goes back to the owner.
Swift doesn't actually own the first six
albums of her catalog.
It's now owned by a fund
called Shamrock Capital.
She's rerecording those albums,
meaning she'll get both
more streaming revenue
and a more valuable catalog.
We estimate that her catalog is worth
about 400 million.
Then, of course, there's her actual property.
That includes a condo and
an estate in Nashville,
an estate in Los Angeles,  a large
apartment in Tribeca in New York City,
as well as a summer house in Rhode Island.
The Rhode Island property is interesting
because it's not really a typical
haunt for celebrities or pop stars.
It's an old world,
sort of old money part of the country.
But it is kind of in keeping
with Taylor Swift's image
of the sort of girl next door,
a little bit of a homebody.
In fact, she's also, has hosted
fans there in the past and
baked them home-baked cookies
at this property.
Making bulk batches of chocolate chip
and toasted coconut cookies.
The total value of her properties
is about 110 million.
Subtract her expenses, taxes,
staff costs and so on,
and you get a net worth
of $1.1 billion.
This was a huge year
for Taylor Swift that tipped
her into a new echelon.
But with the 33-year-old having
just set a concert film record
and the international leg
of her tour getting underway,
she may only be getting started.